bonjour à tous
vous le reconnaissez ce gars là a dit un
jour et vous l'avez déjà entendues soit
le changement que tu veux voir dans le
monde et j'ai récemment saisi le grand
potentiel de cette petite phrase j'ai
une formation d'ingénieur j'adore passer
du temps à l'atelier pour fabriquer des
tas de trucs et avec des copains une
question nous titille depuis longtemps
quel avenir va-t-on pouvoir construire
pour vivre durablement sur cette bonne
vieille terre
alors pour tenter d'avoir des réponses
depuis 2014
on a décidé d'explorer le monde des lots
tech avec notre association le lot tecla
ben je sais pas si vous connaissez les
low tech sont des systèmes simples et
accessibles pour répondre à nos besoins
de base comme l'accès à l'eau à
l'énergie à l'alimentation
de la façon la plus sobre et durable
possible
en 2016 avec corentin le capitaine et
toute l'équipe on a retapé et mis à
l'eau nomades des mers
c'est le catamaran de notre asso il nous
permet de rencontrer des initiatives
low-tech partout autour du monde
à l'intérieur c'est un vrai laboratoire
de test
on a des toilettes sèches des larves de
mouches soldats noirs pour manger nos
déchets organiques
les larves servent ensuite à nourrir des
poules l'uriné sert à faire pousser de
la spiruline à nourrir le système de
culture de légumes feuilles on a des
petites éoliennes fait à partir de
moteurs de vieilles imprimantes pour
alimenter les pompes on a un four
déshydrateur solaire pour faire la
cuisine
on a des pédaliers outils pour percer
est mêlé
dans le bateau on installe tout les low
tech qui nous paraissent intéressantes
pour gagner en autonomie
tous ces systèmes ce sont des dizaines
d'inventeurs de bricoleur de passionnés
rencontré aux quatre coins du globe qui
nous les ont appris pour vous embarquer
un peu dans les escales ici au brésil
pas loin de recife ce sont les élèves de
sebastiao un des piliers du certains une
école qui fonctionne en bonne partie
grâce au low tech
des centaines d'étudiants chaque année
apprennent à les construire
et c'est sébastien ou qui nous a montré
comment fabriquer de petits méthaniseur
pour faire du gaz de cuisine à partir de
déchets organiques
la plus près de chez nous c'est
l'invention de guy isabelle c'est un
passionné du solaire et il a conçu il ya
plus de vingt ans un capteur à air chaud
pour se chauffer c'est une de mes los
teques préféré qui récupère l'énergie du
soleil grâce à des ardoises pour
chauffer de l'air ça lui permet de
gagner gratuitement jusqu'à 6 degrés
dans sa maison l'hiver on l'a découvert
grâce au livre qu'il a écrit pour
partager ses plans et donc le cas ici
avec son turban c'est johnny un
australien installé depuis plus de 50
ans à auroville en inde pas loin de
pondichéry
c'est un champion de la low tech il a
monté une communauté là où il vit dans
la forêt aujourd'hui il passe une bonne
partie de son temps à apprendre tout ce
qui c'est aux enfants des écoles d'à
côté c'est avec lui qu'on a fait nos
fours solaires et il connaît tellement
de trucs
corentin lui a proposé d'embarquer avec
nous sur le bateau et il ya eu plein
d'autres rencontres des eaux gagne en
inde serre dues au cap vert abdoulaye à
dakar à chaque fois on a rencontré des
personnalités curieuses qui aime
partager
mais surtout elle teste elle fabrique
elle expérimente elles sont elles-mêmes
les premiers cobayes de leurs idées et
en fait concrètement elles font ce que
dit gandhi
elle incarne le changement qu'elle veut
le voir dans le monde
et ça ça nous a énormément inspiré à tel
point qu'avec clément un copain
ingénieurs aussi l'hôte et club
on a eu envie de passer à l'action pour
réaliser un vieux rêve construire et
tester la vie dans une maison los teques
autonome tout confort
la moins impactante possible pour
l'environnement et pour notre
portefeuille
cette expérience on a voulu la faire en
bretagne
là où on habite sauf que on avait la
motivation mais on s'est vite rendu
compte d'un petit problème
culturellement on fait pas notre cuisine
au feu de bois et c'est un peu compliqué
en bretagne de tout miser sur le four
solaire
autrement dit les los teques qu'on avait
découvert jusqu'ici elles n'étaient pas
adaptés à notre contexte alors on s'est
dit que des inventeurs de los teques il
aussi sûrement bien d'abord en france et
on a fouillé et là on a découvert au
pied de chez nous un des normes vive et
d'inspiration on en avait même pas
conscience
pour l'explorer en 2017 on a lancé le
low tech tour france pendant un an on a
sillonné nos régions et appris à
construire tout un tas de los teques qui
allait être utile pour notre projet
cette façon-là de voir les choses c'est
ce qu'on appelle la subsidiarité
réponse la solution à un besoin
la solution même la plus pertinente à un
besoin et bien souvent celle pensé conçu
au plus proche du besoin fin 2018 ça y
est on avait entre les mains notre best
of de los teques avec clément on a lancé
la construction de notre prototype de
maison pendant trois mois en acier
raboter assemblée
et la petite maison low-tech est arrivé
dans sa prairie de concarneau en mars
2019 je vous fais la visite
alors côté salle de bain pour utiliser
le moins d'eau possible on a installé
des toilettes sèches
ça permet de réduire sa consommation de
20% et en plus ça fait du compost
on a aussi fait des tests de douja
recyclage pour l'eau on récupère la
pluie sur le toit dont la stocke dans
des cuves de 1000 litres pour boire et
manger en potabilisée les quelques
litres par jour dont on a vraiment
besoin avec un filtre à charbon actif
pour la chauffer on a on utilise un
chauffe eau solaire qu'on a fabriqué à
partir d'échangeurs thermiques de vieux
frigos et une fois utilisé on la traite
dans une petite station de
phytoépuration ou des plantes et surtout
des bactéries vont venir assainir les
eaux usées pour se chauffer on a
installé le capteur airshow de guiza
belle et en complément on a construit un
petit poêle de masse super efficace
conçu par vital bies un poêle y ait du
sud de la france pour réduire à fond
notre consommation d'électricité dans la
cuisine on a décidé de se passer de
grille-pain de bouilloires et même de
frigo on l'a remplacé par un
garde-manger extérieur et pour produire
l'électricité
là c'est moins low-tech c'est pour ça
qu'on voulait en consommer le moins
possible
on a deux panneaux solaires
photovoltaïques et on a branché des
vieilles batteries de bateaux côté
cuisson on a mis en place ce qu'on
appelle une marmite norvégienne c'est
une sorte de thermos qui permet terminer
la cuisson des aliments et de les garder
au chaud ça économise pas mal de gaz et
on s'est plongé comme ça au quotidien
dans notre petit univers low tech n'a
observé notre confort de vie on a mesuré
l'impact écologique de nos systèmes et
on a noté nos dépenses et comme ce qu'on
avait rencontré avant on est devenus
cobaye à notre petite échelle d'un monde
qu'on souhaite voir émerger et cette
expérience elle nous a appris plein de
choses notamment sur la notion
d'innovation en installant la maison
hors des réseaux d'eau et d'électricité
on s'est volontairement positionné sous
contrainte ç'a eu pas mal d'intérêt le
premier c'est que ça force à penser
simple on n'a pas eu de chaudes pendant
six mois pas parce que le chauffe eau
solaire marchait pas mais parce qu'on
avait conçu un système de plomberie trop
complexe pour que ça fonctionne bien et
quand on en a marre de prendre des
douches froides la créativité est semé
tout seul en marche
ça invite aussi à se remettre en rythme
avec les saisons et le climat on a eu
quinze jours de pénurie d'eau en été
2019 et ça c'était la guerre parce qu'on
n'avait pas assez profité de la pluie
les semaines d'avant pour faire les
stocks nos cuves étaient trop petites ça
nous a appris à bien dimensionné nos
systèmes cette mise sous contrainte
elle invite aussi à se réintégrer un
écosystème local et en prendre soin
depuis la fenêtre de la cuisine je vois
les roseaux de la phytoépuration si
jamais j'utilise un produit nocif comme
de l'eau de javel dans mon évier et ben
je risque de voir mourir instantanément
sous mes yeux le système dont j'ai
besoin et le plus gros avantage de la
mise sous contrainte c'est que ça nous a
permis de faire un ménage entre nos
besoins utile et nous envient
superficielles en fait on a expérimenté
un processus qu'on appelle l'innovation
sous contrainte est par nature cette
innovation elle permet la création de
solutions au plus juste du besoin de
manière sobre et efficace
elle aide à orienter le progrès vers un
avenir durable
alors au fur et à mesure de nos essais
de nos erreurs et des leçons qu'on en
tire est le rêve de la maison autonome a
pris forme
on gère nos ressources on vérifie les
stocks dont les cuves on est content que
la pluie arrive on attend le soleil pour
recharger les batteries
ça devient un jeu d'habiter dans la
maison et au bout d'un an on a commencé
à tirer les premiers bilans de nos
observations
grâce à une analyse du cycle de vie de
nos low-tech on a estimé avoir une
empreinte carbone 30 fois plus petit que
la moyenne française sur l'habitat côté
financier on a déboursé 150 euros sur
l'année pour une gaz de cuisine un peu
d'eau et nous les cif qu'on faisait à
l'extérieur alors l'expérience elle
n'est pas du tout parfaite mais ses
résultats sont pour nous un super
indicateur de l'intérêt de continuer
dans une voie low tech pour le futur et
les plus gros bénéfices on les a
constaté sur nous les cobayes
déjà c'est rassurant de voir qu'on peut
vivre avec un bon confort dans une
maison à très faible impact comme on l'a
entièrement construite par nous mêmes on
sait aussi bien ce qui se passe derrière
la prise électrique qui est derrière le
robinet on s'est approprié la technique
et ça ça donne de l'autonomie
et d'ailleurs être autonome en réalité
ça veut dire choisir de qui et de quoi
on veut dépendre
nous on a choisi des éléments de
l'écosystème local qui sont sous nos
yeux et ça ça donne de la sécurité et le
top bonus c'est fait droit dans ses
bottes
on a agi concrètement pour accorder nos
vies avec nos valeurs alors ouais la
maison n'est pas parfaite et nous non
plus mais de se mettre en chemin on est
devenu plus honnête envers nous mêmes et
ça on en est fier et au bout d'un moment
on s'est dit que ce qu'on faisait là bas
ça pouvait peut-être être utile à
d'autres personnes alors on a voulu le
partager
on a fait des vidéos sur internet on a
mis en ligne le rapport de nos
observations
là il ya des gens qu'on commence à nous
appeler on organisait des échanges on a
fait des visites des centaines de
personnes sont venues visiter la maison
des gens ont récupéré des plans nous ont
proposé des idées des améliorations nous
ont inspirés et même mieux comme les low
tech c'est pas compliqué il y en a qui
se sont lancés dans leur propre
construction est ensemble on a vu
d'autres idées d'expérience en appart
dans un immeuble à l'échelle d'une ville
d'une région
quitte à petit il ya de nouveaux projets
qui se mettent en route et c'est ça le
plus magique
à chaque fois que quelqu'un vie et
partage une expérience qui lui tient à
coeur
ça représente une toute petite goutte
d'eau mais ces petites gouttes d'eau
elles font très souvent germer des
graines dans l'esprit de ceux qui la
reçoivent
et moi je suis convaincu que si chacun
de nous apporte sa goutte d'eau c'est un
fleuve qui n'est pour irriguer le monde
de demain et on en a besoin
c'est pour ça que ça vaut le coup de
s'arrêter une minute sur la phrase de
gandhi on doit tous sans courage et à
expérimenter les changements qu'on veut
voir dans le monde
merci
[Applaudissements]